my name is katya moskowicz and i'm the
editorial lead of ibm
research and we are here today at ibm
research
europe in zurich switzerland next to me
here
is a full-size model of a quantum
computer
so i know it looks like a really pretty
chandelier
i realized that but actually it's not
even though i would love to have one
in my house i think it looks super cool
but it is a model of a quantum
computer and uh that's what we're gonna
be talking today
uh talking about today uh the state of
quantum computing
joining me uh today is one of my amazing
colleagues
uh ibm physicist heike ryle she's gonna
be joining us
from uh quantum lab here
at ibm research europe and uh
she is actually uh the quantum lead
of ibm research europe fun fact by the
way before switching to physics
heike used to design furniture i think
it's actually quite amazing
as um as far as career switches go from
furniture design to
quantum computing heike is also an ibm
fellow
and as of late last year she actually
became
a fellow of the american physical
society which is a pretty huge honor in
physics so um before i hand it over to
you heike i actually wanted to say
welcome to everybody who is watching us
please do send us your questions on
youtube we'll try to uh get through as
many questions as we possibly can
during the discussion and uh with that
heike over to you uh tell us where you
are tell us
what what is that big weird white
cylinder next to you
yeah hi katya great uh seeing you here
although you are in a different building
right so we are here live
in the in one of our quantum labs at the
ibm research campus
in zurich and you've seen the pretty
picture of the surrey campus on top at
the beginning
it's really a beautiful campus but it's
not only a beautiful campus but also
beautiful and
very exciting lab here because
we are actually next to a lab where 35
years ago
nobel prize winning experiments were
done and my colleagues at that time
they discovered high temperature
superconductivity
so back to your question kaja of where
are we what are we seeing here
and so behind me or next to me you see
actually uh
one of these uh one part of a quantum
computer
right it's a more complex thing what you
see here is a dilution refrigerator
we call it also fridge and it actually
cools down
the quantum processors to very low
temperature
and much lower than actually your fridge
at home where you store your food
so it goes down to um almost
zero temperature to about 10 to 20
millikelvin
this is how cold the quantum processor
needs to be
and you see it's also quite a big thing
as you've seen and we also have
connected to the fridge here
then also electronics where we then can
communicate
with the quantum processor so so hold on
hi guys
that's that's really cool but is that i
heard correct me if i'm wrong but i
heard that it's like the coldest place
in the universe is that right like it's
colder than outer space or something
like that
is that true that's definitely right
it's actually about 100 times colder
than outer space
and um i mean this is a demonstration
also what technology is able to do right
it cools down things and
actually today it's done in a you know
quite um
engineered manner like 20 years ago this
was much more cumbersome
for physicists to do these low
temperature experiments
but today that's really a technology
which is
very much used and not so much of a
difficulty anymore
wow well that's that's indeed um amazing
well um can we actually see the inside
of that fridge or
uh would we be able to yeah like to you
know open it up
and see the the model that uh that we
see here so
unfortunately in the lab here right now
we cannot uncover this thing
because we're actually doing experiments
so my colleagues they actually run
experiments right now
therefore the fridge has to stay
complete and cold
but what you see here now in the video
which is shown
is how this fridge is kind of uncovered
uh to the inside um there are different
cylinders which
need to be taken off when you need to
exchange the quantum processor
and um they um you know then you see the
inner core
of the inner life of the quantum
computer
and perhaps we can also show a more
detailed picture
of the inner life as we can't see it
very well and i explain a few things
towards that
so because we have the electronics
outside we have room temperature outside
but then we go
to a temperature 100 times colder than
outer space
and so we run actually um here the what
you see in this figure is actually that
the
quantum processor sits behind this
cylinder at the bottom which you see and
this is where the coldest spot is in the
quantum processor
and then what you also see are these
lines which are running down
and these are super conducting coaxial
cables
where actually microwaves are
transported in order to
talk to the quantum processor behind
and all this is inside this fridge um
it's uh currently used
and uh that's why we can't open it katya
wow well that that certainly looks um
very futuristic right and even
much cooler than this model next to me i
now feel like i'm
yeah i would love to be next to the real
thing
uh but also i remember the first time i
visited ibm research a couple years ago
and i remember entering the quantum
computing lab
and uh like looking around like thinking
okay
where is the keyboard where is the
screen like where is the quantum screen
i was thinking you know
so it definitely doesn't look like a
regular computer
right it looks like as i said the
chandelier but not a regular computer
at all and you mentioned uh microwave
pulses
high key is not like the same kind of
microwave radiation that i use at home
when i
i don't know warm up my pizza in the
microwave also you probably shouldn't do
it with pizza but
you know is that the same thing yeah
it's a
it's also microwaves it's a bit of a
different frequency which we are using
but we use these microwave pulses to
actually
talk to the quantum processor uh to
bring information in
to run the calculation and then also
read out
the the result of the calculation and
as you said it's not really not like a
typical
classical digital computer as you know
where you have a keyboard and you have a
screen and it's used transistors as
the smallest parts of it but it's a
completely different
mechanism and physics behind how these
computers work
so actually in these quantum computers
uh there are qubits used so called
quantum bits
which are actually the unit of
information carrier here and
in classical digital computers which we
all know we use so-called bits
and we know that they can be a one or a
zero
and then we can encode information in
these ones and zeros and we can do
processes of processing of information
so in the quantum computer it's really
working different
because the laws of quantum physics are
used
to do calculation and so as i mentioned
we use quantum bits or qubits and they
can be
a one a zero or something in between
so this is one quantum phenomena
there are actually other quantum
phenomena also used for the the
calculations like entanglement and
interference
and because of this quantum mechanics
and quantum physics the power of these
quantum computers can be really
exponentially different
than the classical computers and that
makes them really
interesting and really a breakthrough
technology which is coming
that sounds really cool but can we
already use them today
like can i access one and and and use it
freely for
like whatever i'm working on yes
actually you can and you can
do this already there's four years
because already in 2016
we have brought the first quantum
computer at that time
was five qubits to the world we made it
accessible through the ibm cloud
and people could just uh you know log in
using a normal classical computer to log
into the quantum computer
and run quantum algorithms on the
computer
of course um a lot has changed right and
for me it's actually very exciting
because when
i studied physics it was kind of a
theoretical concept which
which was discussed but now they're real
and in the last four years so many
things have happened
um great technological development and
breakthroughs have been accomplished
we have increased the number of qubits
from five to 65
also the quality of the quantum
computation
was increased although this is measured
in quantum volume i don't want to go
into detail in that
but a lot of things have really happened
so it's not only something
which just stands in the lab like like
here where we do experiments but it's
actually already moving into
um data centers uh where they are used
through the cloud
um as normal devices wow okay well
it does sound very impressive i don't
know about the rest of the audience but
i am you know positively impressed uh
so you know how can i use them you said
i could use them so can i use a quantum
computer to i don't know create like a
better
powerpoint presentation or something
although that's by powerpoint
powerpoints
probably is not the best example but you
know why don't you tell us
what we can use it for yeah so
um it's probably not the best use to be
honest right
for text processing or doing better
presentations it's really not the right
means
because you have to solve problems with
a quantum processor
where the nature of quantum physics can
really help you
and but these challenges or these
problems are actually there in many
industries so these are mathematical
problems
where the um the complexity of the
calculation
actually increases exponentially with a
number of parameters for example
and this can be in materials
analysis or materials development
um if you're looking for new molecules
and
these molecules can actually um
not precisely calculated by digital
classical computers
because molecules are also based on the
quantum mechanics
and so building computers which
intrinsically exploit
quantum mechanics is a much better tool
to calculate the properties of molecules
precisely
and thus be able to also predict new
molecules
or new materials why is this important
materials you can find actually in
almost every industry
whether you go into the car industry you
need
better batteries you need better
materials
for batteries you want to have more
lightweight materials
if you look into energy uh you want to
also have like
materials which can absorb carbon
dioxide
so there are a lot of these materials um
challenges where innovation and
materials can bring a big value
also in transport supply chain right you
if you have um difficult routes if you
have manufacturing processes which need
optimization
um also for finances industry
there are many different examples where
these mathematical problems appear
which today in classical computers we
only use
like approximations but they cannot
always solve your problem
wow okay um i can see that questions are
actually starting to come in hiking so
there is a question for you
here i'm just gonna read it uh doesn't
the temperature create
problems like some kind of shrinking of
the materials due to the low
temperatures
um yes it's i mean it's right that
materials shrink when you
cool things down and you have to take
these type of things into account right
when you build for example devices then
you know the materials should have like
similar
um temperature behavior otherwise you
can run into problems
but there is actually a lot of knowledge
in um the
in research and in doing those
temperature characterization and
experiments
and so we have learned also how to build
those devices
that they kind of work and survive
these low temperature that you can heat
them up again
and that you can cool them down again
and they still work
wow that that definitely sounds uh
fascinating
so just to back up a bit so you were
talking about these
different uh applications or for for
quantum computers um and
uh i think you mentioned like chemistry
and finance so if i understand correctly
it has to do with optimizations so maybe
i could even like i don't know
input my picture in a quantum computer
it would give me lots of different
options of how to i don't know
style my hair or like get a new haircut
or
do you think we're going to be using uh
quantum computers for for
stuff like that or it's never going to
be used by individuals but mostly like
to solve global problems
i'm so i'm not too sure about your
haircut whether it helps you there right
but
as mentioned they're really very
exciting uh or very important problems
technical problems in many different
industries
which can benefit of quantum computers
and there are different classes one is
for sure the optimization
optimization of as i mentioned like
transport routes
or in the finance industries
if you want to do risk analysis um you
you have to do monte carlo simulations
for example and also in
quantum monte carlo simulations can help
you so having
we actually have here developed an ibm a
um quantum algorithm
which can be used and this we also
demonstrated that this can create
a significant advantage and can speed up
the things
uh quadratically great um i have
uh another question that just uh came in
for you heike
and it has to do with quantum
superposition could you please explain
to us
very simply what quantum superposition
is
yes so that's a phenomena um you know
having graphs
it's much easier to explain but let's
start like this and um you have
like a um imagine an
arrow which can point up or can point
down
and uh so to the north portal the south
pole and uh this gives you like a
one or a zero state right represented
and in quantum computing you can
actually create a superposition
out of these two vectors this means you
can take
a number of times the up arrow plus a
number of times the
down arrow and this is a new state which
can also be represented by the quantum
bit
and uh in the end you can visualize this
by the so-called block
sphere where every state on the
surface of a sphere can be represented
by this superposition and so you can
imagine now with these one cubit you can
describe every every position on the
surface of the block sphere
and this is one um yeah one
mechanism of why quantum computers are
so powerful
wow so um just to clarify though so when
you're describing qubits
uh they clearly behave like atoms but
they are something physical right that
we actually create like
what's inside a quantum computer like uh
can you just describe describe a little
bit um what a qubit would look like i
guess uh to to human
yes a cupid it can also be called kind
of an
artificial atom and
why is it called like this in an atom
you have like and it goes a bit deep
into
in the physics i'm sorry about that but
you have different energy levels
in an atom and you in principle create
now
an artificial atom which also has
different energy levels
and these you need two because these two
represent
kind of your one and your zero and um
you can implement them in different
physical systems
um we actually what we use here in in
our quantum computers are super
conducting josephson junctions
and these are actually it's kind of a um
we can call it a simple structure
because in the end it's two
superconducting metal layers uh which
are
which have an insulator in between and
there you can create kind of a quant
these quantum states which you can then
use for your quantum calculations
okay great wow um and where are we today
was quantum computers then
oh yeah today it's really exciting as i
mentioned we have uh
increased the number of qubits we
increased the quality
of the uh the measurements and
the control of the qubits we have also
you know designed and engineered the
system to be more robust and stable
to kind of improve really all the
different parameters
and just at the end of last year in
september we have
also announced the roadmap which we are
pursuing in this roadmap you actually
see the different
processors the different quantum
processors
and last year we have demonstrated the
so-called hummingbird
it has 65 cubits and we are now on a
path
to really um increase the number of
cupids um
continuously so this year we will show
we will demonstrate
a 127 qubit chip which is eagle
and as you can imagine for each of those
steps we have significant
technical improvements which are
implemented in these different
generations
and in 2022 we show a 433 cupid chip
and then it's really getting also very
exciting because we kind of break the
1000 qubit barrier
and reach more than 1 000 cubits in our
condor chip
and again technological improvements
are required for this we are working on
them
and this demonstration really is then a
demonstration of above thousand qubits
and it will allow us um and out of the
world of course more complex problems uh
to be solved
and um this is integrated also with uh
with
a whole infrastructure right because
it's not only about the hardware
there is also the infrastructure around
the software how to control
how to how to write software um
developing applications etc so there are
lots of things which are going on
currently wow it's interesting that you
just mentioned fundamental problems and
uh
we've just actually received the
question uh pretty much about that uh so
somebody here is asking
is quantum only for computing faster and
having
parallel processing or is it also being
used for answering fundamental physics
questions
and that's a that has the different
components of this uh
question and um because
quantum actually is we call it fast i
mean often it's called faster
but quantum computers are faster than
classical computers
but that's not uh we should phrase it
differently because they actually use a
different
way of computation and so for certain
problems they can be faster but for
other problems like your word processing
what you mentioned at the beginning they
may not be faster
so we cannot kind of generalize it and
then but it also can be used um and
quantum technologies are also used for
sensing applications so um
there is an advantage also for using
the phenomena of quantum physics and
quantum mechanics
for other areas and the
third question was also uh can we help
fundamental basic um
experiments or whatever right and that's
actually exciting because
i mentioned before many of these things
are related to materials and improving
materials
and so my colleagues have
35 years ago got the nobel prize for the
high temperature superconducting but
high temperature
was still only in the kind of nitrogen
liquid nitrogen region
and so the whole community is kind of
looking also for
high temperature really high temperature
which means kind of room temperature
um superconductivity and actually
quantum computers
may be able to help right and uh if if
if you have the right system around then
the hope is also to predict materials
which can solve those fundamental
questions
wow okay well um and so just uh to go
back to what you were saying about uh
the qubits and how like the
superconducting qubits and how we're
making them
so if i understand correctly you know
quantum computers of the future will
have
like thousands of these physical qubits
with physical things right that we're
going to be cramming into
this wonderful chandelier here right so
i just can't imagine if we're cramming
thousands and thousands of them in there
at some point
this whole beautiful thing is just gonna
collapse right
yeah so of course there uh you know this
is kind of the start it's not the end
it's uh there is a
um i mean this is also a small fridge
right and for bringing
like millions of
cupids into such a fridge it needs also
different technology
and i said for each of these steps we
have new technology coming in
and one of the things which comes in
beyond the thousand cubit
is really kind of a so-called
superfridge so
this is one technology which we are
working on
this uh so-called golden eye
and we also have a picture here where
you see it it's uh
you see the dimensions right i'm
standing next to this one so
and um jay um who is our
leader of the uh of the quantum program
he is actually inside this new fridge
which we are developing
and uh this is also technology which we
in-house develop um in order to go to
the next level to really prepare
everything
and for being able to build also quantum
computers
with millions of quantum bits so you see
the fridge here is about
10 foot high and six foot wide
and it's already tested and and you know
certain feasibility tests are made
and there is further development towards
having this ready
when we then uh you know get to these
numbers
this is one example um but the other
thing is if you have
if you continue scaling the number of
qubits then you also want to have
technology available
which actually connects different uh
quantum processors
so we are working also on connecting
different quantum processors
and so kind of create like an internet
of where different quantum processors
are connected with each other
okay wow great thank you for that um
another question from the audience here
uh kind of personal question what use
cases are you
working on okay uh so i
i don't necessarily work on application
use cases but
my team here so stefan verna and also
ivano javanelli and the team
with colleagues around the world at ibm
they're and they're working on
use cases and also actually with a lot
of
partners in industry because you know we
are the compute experts
and we are we work together with
partners who are the industry experts
um to figure out what are the relevant
use cases
in each of the industries to go after
and provide
really the quantum advantage um and the
value for the industry
and so i hope you know next time katya
for your next uh
um webinar i already have a suggestion
to invite uh stefan and ivana they can
tell you then more about their quantum
application they are working on
wonderful yeah absolutely sounds
fascinating um
another question here if someone wants
to work on quantum software development
what would you need to study that's an
interesting one
yes though actually this is um changing
uh
quite a lot because we are developing a
lot
of the software stack and today we
actually have made an important
announcement
um also to really make it
easy make it frictionless for people to
develop
quantum applications and use quantum
computers
so we have uh for what do you need to
study
i mean today i would recommend um take
computer science for example right but
also have uh
quantum uh courses and i think that's
actually where a lot of them
but also physics and their computing
courses so i think it's right now
actually a mix
because you should have a bit of a
quantum
quantum physics background but also have
skills uh on the other side
and in the end today we really you can
use quantum computers already by just
knowing python and
um and um yeah worked with our
kids with um the open source kisket um
work software to use quantum computers
so
actually it's a very easy um
level to go and to um yeah com
programming quantum computers and work
with quantum computers
and um i mean yeah so these programs
also in the education
area are there's a lot of dynamics
because in former time
as i mentioned before only physicists
kind of worked with quantum computers
and programmed them but this is really
changing a lot
today the these courses are already
happening
for all the different um
um right um study subjects whether it's
from engineering computer science
chemists
um and et cetera to kind of bring the
basics for quantum computation
[Music]
yeah well um and in my mind
uh now we kind of come one that we
mentioned education
uh we come to the most important topic
of of this discussion anyway
uh do you think the world is actually
ready for quantum computing
i mean um okay we've got uh we've got
these machines right
and but but um you mentioned that
they're not uh
we haven't reached quantum advantage yet
so they're not better than classical
computers just
yet but imagine if if they if we do
reach quantum advantage say
tomorrow or like a week from now or even
six months from now do you think the
world is ready for quantum computing
like will the companies around the world
suddenly all be able to like know how to
use it what to use it for
um or not what's what's your view on
that are we ready for quantum computing
yes
i think people are getting ready right
and i would say you better get ready
because it's really a very dynamic
environment a lot of things are
happening
the technology is developing very fast
and
different to classic computers the
scaling behavior of quantum computers is
also different
so um it's not like a linear scaling as
we are used to
in uh in the normal transistor
area but it's really um scaling with a
different behavior
and so we expect that in uh
at the in 2023 2023 actually
uh we there is kind of a turning point
where then we can demonstrate quantum
advantage and uh you are then better
ready
to can use quantum computers so what
does it mean using quantum computers
right
um you should have identified like the
uh the
um areas where quantum computers can
help you in your industry
what are the biggest pain points biggest
challenges where
the fit with quantum computers and um
this requires and also of course that
you have a workforce which has um
a team uh which knows a bit about
quantum and can have the industry
expertise and can then also together
kind of identify
uh these workloads and yeah i think it's
uh we are really in a dynamic world
where you have to get ready
uh because quantum computers are there
and they will develop fast
and then there's an advantage and you
are better able to use it
[Music]
um i am just getting more and more
questions here and
uh the next one is actually i'm we're
gonna we're gonna jump back to the
beginning of the discussion i'm sorry
for that haiky but uh
just rewind a little bit this um uh
audience member is asking can you please
explain
how quantum entanglement is used in how
the quantum computer actually operates
yes so entanglement um it's actually one
of these
behaviors which is also very weird
um because you kind of bring um
cupids together you entangle them this
means they are
certainly have properties which are
really connected with each other
then you separate them and you change
one you measure one for example and you
exactly know also what the property of
the other one is
and these are weird things which we are
not used to
in in our daily lives in the classical
world
but in the quantum world they can be
created
cupids can be entangled and they then
also provide kind of
the advantage or the power which
is utilized by the quantum computation
i remember reading that albert einstein
once said that quantum entanglement
was like spooky action at a distance
and it kind of makes sense right because
as you say
if one atom or qubit in this case
changes its state
the entangled partner even if it's like
light years away
well simultaneously changes state too
which is like
and i don't know it's completely
mind-blowing right
yeah because i mean at that time right
when uh when the uh
the when it was clear that light travels
at a constant speed
and light is needed to kind of transfer
information this was a real phenomenon
people
it was very hard to understand and it's
it's still kind of
is right because it's not in our
classical world present
so i think we also kind of get to get
get to have this or this intuition um
and uh for quantum mechanics and quantum
behavior
yeah absolutely and uh so you you you
were talking earlier um
about how uh people could uh use quantum
computers even today
and i would assume you know in the
future the process of actually
uh connecting to a quantum computer
would be would be similar which is
through
the cloud and we've we've got a question
here from one of uh
our audience uh uh from one of our
viewers um
who is asking how are quantum computers
actually hosted or you know connected to
the cloud if you can explain
the way they are connected to the cloud
okay i mean today um we you know
we have a certain marketing to perhaps
we can also show the uh the development
roadmap in that regard which also shows
a bit holistically
how we integrate uh
quite the soft the hardware the software
and also then the building the
applications and
we need we need to connect
of course the quantum computer which is
sitting here
to classically computers and through
these classical computers in the cloud
you actually have the access so that's
why you can connect with your mobile
phone or
with your classical computer to the
cloud
and can access our quantum computers but
of course there's a lot of things
behind which may go a bit too much into
detail to explain here
but um we are because you you run
certain
circuits and uh you run algorithms and
uh
we are continuously also um developing
that the architecture which is actually
has been uh announced today so that's
really brand new
uh this is an announcement of today
which you see which is a holistic and
integrated picture
of the full stack development uh which
we do
from the hardware to the software and
also
the applications part and providing then
also the
the service through the cloud and
because we talked a bit about also the
what you need to know in order to use
quantum computers and of course in the
end
we want to have like a frictionless
development and frictionless use of
people using quantum computers this
means
if you are in chemistry and your job is
to
design new drugs then you should
kind of use the software and the tools
which are used today
but behind the scene quantum computers
are used in order to solve the problems
but you should not need to learn special
things in order to use them
in the most efficient way
yeah i think you've just actually
addressed the next question we have here
which is um about exactly that so
somebody's asking
would one write custom quantum
algorithms for applications now
or would algorithms mainly be written uh
by academia
or quantum experts and only used by
by in by the industry so what what's
your view on that i guess
it's different now and and what you've
just described was a road map right
yeah exactly it's different now but we
are constantly developing and to make it
much
easier for everyone to use quantum
computers and not be a specialist
of you know how i mean you have to kind
of translate your problem into a quantum
algorithm
and then it depends also on the hardware
how you implement it
and so you really need um we are
developing this whole
um infrastructure that for the user it's
really frictionless to use them
and so um if we uh go back to what we
were talking like when we were talking
about
education and universities so what is
happening today i mean
for people to actually understand what
quantum computers can
can offer them in the future do you
think more universities should be kind
of actively introducing quantum
computing
into their curricula and maybe even on a
high school level
and it doesn't like i don't know in my
view it doesn't even necessarily have to
be about programming specifically
but just to kind of introduce like 16 17
year olds
to to this idea that soon in the future
it will like if they will go into like
material design for example
they may have access to these machines
that are that that are just you know
coming online and will hopefully uh
become fully functional in a few a few
years from now so do you think we should
do kind of more
in terms of education educating the
future workforce
in that regard yeah of course i mean
there is
much more to do it's also of course an
exciting uh topic to learn about
and uh it will have quite some impact in
the future
so as said right you're better prepared
for it
and this means there are also different
dimensions of course
um at the universities for example and
in research
there is a really tremendous dramatic
increase in also using quantum computers
and working on algorithms
and so um if you look around whether
it's in europe or u.s and
everywhere the universities expand their
programs in quantum computing in the
theory
and also using quantum computers there
are extra
curricular made for as i mentioned
before
not that only physicists learn about
quantum computers but that also quantum
computers how to program them how to use
them
is uh taught um to engineers and
chemists and um
you know even finance experts etc so
it's
really broadening this is what we see um
we also
develop actually quite a lot of yeah
tools uh and also programs uh where we
help
uh to bring together and to explain
quantum computing
help people using quantum computers show
them how to program them
you can see for example youtube videos
where you can dive into detail and how
to do it
um and uh also in collaboration with
universities
so that's the university level then if
you go to that company level
it's again uh also i mean in the end you
want to also educate your workforce in
quantum computing
you want to build up a team also of
experts that they can
identify um the use cases and can also
lay out a strategy for
um for making use and of the quantum
advantage
and integrating it in the high school
it's an interesting topic also because
i personally think um the earlier you
kind of get in touch
with these weird phenomena um the easier
it may be for you to grasp it and to
think
like it right um i'm jake and beta also
once said you think too classically
and i think the earlier we start to um
to
see and visualize and experience quantum
behavior
uh then the more an intuition we can uh
you know ex get and having an intuition
also helps
to then actually become creative in that
space
and so i think learning early
the way how to do it is of course
different than how you how do you do it
after you may have studied a certain
subject
um but i think there are cool things i
mean for example a colleague here
he looks into quantum games uh so using
the
quantum physics and exploring how to use
quantum computers in the
in games and that's also one way to kind
of
you know get in touch with it and be
excited about it and then learn about it
yeah absolutely i mean quantum gaming
quantum
video games it's completely i don't know
mind-blowing i think
when you're when when you're playing a
video game
and you know that it's been designed on
a quantum computer or maybe like you
yourself could like design a quantum
video game i i think is it's absolutely
uh
absolutely amazing um so we've got
another question here
actually uh we've talked about it a
little bit but uh could you just explain
maybe a little bit more in detail for
our viewers
what is actually quantum advantage
yes uh so quantum advantage we define um
as
the state where we solve
a problem which is of high value
with quantum computers which cannot be
solved with
any biggest supercomputer you can ever
build
in the world and this is something where
we expect this to come
end of 2023 where we have
reached kind of the thousand cupid
barrier and have
broken this barrier and there there
should be then
problems which really can be solved and
provide the value
with quantum computers today as we
discussed
these are smaller problems we can solve
but we learn a lot right because we
learn about how
how to write the quantum algorithms
which then can also be used with a
scaled quantum computer
great and um so we we talked about uh
you know uh creating more and more of
these uh
qubits and hopefully you know at some
point uh
there will be hundreds thousands of
these qubits and
uh will uh will reach the point of uh
the qubits being uh you know quite quite
uh
good quality right so to speak but d do
you think i mean there's a term
in in quantum computing error correction
so what could you just explain there's
one of one of our viewer viewers here is
asking what
actually is uh error correction what is
it why
why is it important yeah so error
correction is actually something which
is used
also in in classical computers right in
a memory cell for example when you store
information and you also you have ones
and zeros
but sometimes an error happens and then
suddenly the zero switches into a one
and uh this brings you an error so what
you do is actually in classical
you kind of copy the things uh and have
like three times the one
you store not only one one but you store
it three times and then
if one switches then you say okay that's
uh that may be an error and you can
correct for it
and in quantum computing that's
unfortunately not so easy
because there is also quantum physics
where you say you cannot copy a quantum
state
so you need to find other tricks um but
you also have like
noise in the system and you may also
when you do your calculations and apply
your gates
you may um in um they the errors may
appear and so you also have to in the
end correct for those errors
uh to get the exact results and
this is important for the universal
quantum computer so we can also already
do calculations like quantum simulations
if
if qubits have still some errors and
this error correction needs then um a
number of
qubits which uh work together in order
to correct for this error which may
appear
so the uh the then error corrected qubit
has kind of more qubits than a physical
is are more cupid's than a physical
cupid
wow so uh yes it's uh fascinating that
physicists are already working on this
error correction
kind of looking into the future right
and uh it's uh it's amazing so one once
we get there once we
are able to create uh more and more of
these physical qubits we'll also
hopefully be able to then apply this
message that we are working on today and
correct those errors so it's it's really
um
work of the future kind of shaping the
future in in in my
in my opinion um but um what what about
the infrastructure though so for
instance if um
you know if we do reach quantum
advantage and hopefully we will reach
quantum advantage
and then uh everybody starts uh as you
say like you know
there's uh education and workforce
development and suddenly
the whole world is using quantum
computers so
how is it going to be can you just
describe like uh how many machines are
we going to need are they going to be
all tucked away in data centers or like
what is it going to actually look like
yeah so um i mean just coming back to
the era correction you mentioned i mean
at you know when we are about the 1000
cubit barrier then we can also start to
do error correction
and then really the uh the things are
getting
getting a big momentum even more and for
the infrastructure this means then
you're able to
you you get the quantum advantage and
then there is also of course
even more need for quantum computers and
we already see a lot of need for quantum
computers
so we started in 2016 with one quantum
computer online
today we already have 32 quantum
computers online
and what does it mean today they're
actually in
data centers and as you know a lot of
data centers are used
there are many kind of mathematical
problems i mentioned where you could use
quantum computers
so i see this really expanding very much
and uh
i mean you know someone said when the
digital computers have been uh used
or started in 1943 actually watson said
oh there will be
not more than five computers in the
world and i think this uh you know we
already passed so
uh it shows us a bit i'm looking back
um and you look at the semiconductor
industry 70 years ago
would people have imagined that we you
know use mobile phones for doing complex
calculations
uh that you have mobile phones that we
do a video chat and all these things
so you see that actually having quantum
computers there will be
more things which can be done with them
and there will be more development which
actually
expands into things which we may not be
able to envision even today
and so i think it's therefore it's
really a very exciting time also to be
part of this mission
to create more complex uh quantum
computers
uh to make to reach the quantum
advantage and to apply them
in uh for very relevant problems
yeah it's uh i mean quantum center
quantum data centers of the future it
just
really sounds super cool um but what
about um
ai artificial intelligence and there's
somebody asking here uh
how can quantum computers help in deep
learning
and indeed i mean uh we are making
tremendous progress in
in ai right so i would i would assume
that uh
ai and quantum computers will kinda have
to we'll have to work together somehow
right
what's your view yeah there actually
also one application which i
did not yet mention is machine learning
uh quantum computers uh
and machine learning and there's also a
lot of research and um
and development going on to develop new
algorithms
and also to figure out how can quantum
computers help and actually recently
also
uh quite important the work has been
done within ibm to demonstrate that
the entanglement and quantum feature
spaces can really help
to improve the classification
in data sets and so we have also
research projects where we for example
work also together with a cern here in
switzerland
as you know they have very complex data
sets uh they have the
large hadron collider they are preparing
for new detectors
to come where they get lots of data sets
or lots of data and they are they can
actually not store all the data
so they have to extract patterns from
the beginning
and so they just kind of then store the
extraction but this means they cannot go
back and check later
and so with quantum computers you could
because of the dimensionality you can
explore
higher dimensional patterns or use
the uh the quantum computers and the
entanglement
to get um to use quantum feature spaces
where you can do a much better
classification does provide also an
advantage
so that is currently explored and there
are other
similar examples and also for machine
learning
well um we have about eight minutes left
so
probably just enough time for two three
more questions uh
okay i know it's it's getting pretty
late in zurich
uh and everybody probably wants to go
have dinner
uh but this one is pretty good can you
tell us
what are other interesting scientific
technological developments that could
influence the development of quantum
computers
so it's an interesting question
i mean technologies which uh i've
mentioned one right if you look at the
at the uh uh fridge uh because
such a fridge is needed to really build
the mill and to
enable the millions of devices cooled
then there are also other
implementations of quantum computers
which you can think of where also more
progress
is needed and then materials analysis
in order to further improve the quality
of the quantum bits
understanding where noise may come from
which is observed and
also quantum computers can perhaps in
the end help by developing new materials
which then also provide new insights
and improvements for the current
technology
there's also electronics which is
developed so the holistic system is
really
um you know improved and further
developed
um in order to move to the bigger
systems
well um i guess we only have time
probably for the last question here and
it's an interesting one it's on security
so uh what is quantum safe cryptography
and does it actually exist
um so so um can you repeat the question
actually i i
didn't hear it well what is quantum safe
cryptography and does it exist
oh yeah um yes so quantum safe
cryptography
i mean people may ask what is it right
um
what does it mean and um quantum
computers
are so powerful or will become so
powerful in the future
that they may be able to actually um
factorize big numbers which is for
classical digital computers not possible
they may need like billions uh billions
of years but a quantum computer could
uh using shores algorithms if you have a
universal quantum computer
then do this like in hours and this is
still far away but this is kind of a
risk that then the current cryptography
would no longer work
and uh and therefore we actually are
already also here at ibm
develop quantum safe cryptography and
this is a different mathematical
algorithm you use in order to encode
your information
and this can actually not be solved
very quickly by quantum computers so
it's a mathematical problem
where quantum computers would not
provide a speed up in order to then
um decode the information
and this is currently developed i mean
there are
quantum safe algorithms there are like
suggestions
and there is actually also competition
of which ones
will win and then will become a new
standard for how to encode
um stored information and um
some of as i mentioned we have a team
here who is working on this and they
already implement this
also in in storage um
in storage uh parts that this can be
sold and
make your information already today safe
for future for computers to come
wonderful well thank you so much heike
that's uh that's
really really amazing and informative um
one last question i have when do you
think we're gonna have
a replica of that to take home as a
chandelier
really you know i mean we can use
our skills right as you mentioned the
beginning i have uh furniture making
background so we can build our one
amazing that's what i wanted to hear all
right well thank you so much heike thank
you so much everybody for joining us
here today
uh if you have any other questions just
find us on twitter
and we'll be happy to get in touch with
you and hopefully we'll see you at some
point soon again thank you
and bye thank you katya take care
everyone
bye bye
you